des fruits des légumes l'abondance de
l'été pour se nourrir mais aussi pour
nourrir les cent mille milliards de
micro organismes que sont les bonnes
bactéries dans notre intestin ce que
l'on appelle le microbiote
certains disent même que c'est notre
deuxième cerveau quand on mange en
fonction des saisons on dorloter on
cherche nos micros organismes
intestinaux alors évidemment fallait
venir faire notre ton au marché
andrée anne martin et nutritionniste
elle a lancé un défi à la population de
renforcer son micro billotte je vais
vous prendre une petite botte d'aspergés
vous plaît aujourd'hui elle fait le
plein des nouvelles récoltes au marché
on dit le deuxième cerveau parce qu'il
ya énormément de neurones de nerfs de
communication qui se fait avec le
cerveau dans aux ajustements et en soit
l'été cinq produits tous ces
neurotransmetteurs beaucoup de notre
sérotonine un neurotransmetteur du
bien-être est produit dans l'intestin
beaucoup de neurotransmetteurs associés
à la gestion du stress est produit dans
l'intestin également donc c'est
définitivement notre deuxième serveur
elle tente de sensibiliser sa communauté
sur les réseaux sociaux à l'importance
d'améliorer l'équilibré de son
microbiote intestinal
quand on fait le plein de couleurs ont
fait le plein de vitamines et minéraux
dans un premier temps mais aussi de
fibres alimentaires
l'élection nos bactéries intestinales et
aussi d'un type d'antix d'anglais
particulier les polyphénols et les
polyphénols font croître les bonnes
familles de bactéries dans notre
intestin
chaque individu possède un micro billes
est différent ils se constituent à 60%
dans le ventre de notre mère à la
naissance et tout au long de l'enfance
selon l'environnement il y a donc une
proportion de 40 % que l'on peut
contrôler et améliorer à l'aide entre
autres de l'alimentation et via cinq
éléments bien particulier soit les
fibres alimentaires les prébiotiques les
probiotiques les polyphénols et les bons
gras des nutriments qui joue un rôle
important
la nourriture préférée des bactéries
c'est ce sont les fibres alimentaires ce
sont les végétaux alors elle digère les
fibres alimentaires et à partir de ça
elles produisent des substances qui sont
bonnes pour nous que ce soit des
vitamines des substances anti
inflammatoires elles vont aussi un dea
la communication avec notre cerveau avec
nos poumons avec tout notre corps est
est ce que les fibres vont tenir fer
s'est stabilisé notre niveau d'énergie
un dîner nos taux de mauvais cholestérol
nourrir nos bonnes familles de bactéries
intestinales ça va aider autant à
prévenir les maladies chroniques qu'on
connaît bien et aussi à aider pour
certaines problématiques de santé
mentale d'une les symptômes dépressifs
mieux gérer le stress qui aurait pensé
que la gestion du stress pouvait passer
par les couleurs comme étant dans notre
assiette
mais dans nos assiettes il manque de
végétaux car on ne consomme que environ
20 grammes de fibres par jour l'oeil de
nouvelles recommandations qui s'en
viennent on parle de 45 à 55 grammes de
fibres par jour d'où l'importance de
faire de l'éducation de parler de
l'importance des fibres et surtout de
donner des exemples concrets pour y
arriver la semaine prochaine on pimp
votre microbiote intestinal
dans son défi andréanne glisse ses bons
nutriments du règne végétal dans chacun
des repas de la journée et ce pendant 28
jours on décortique repas par repas
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut intégrer une demi tasse de
plus de légumes ici un petit coup il a
quelques noix et graines ici donc on est
capable de cette façon d'augmenter la
quantité totale de fibres comprend dans
la journée au déjeuner par exemple elle
ajoute du pain de grains entiers des
fruits et des graines un oeil ou gourou
ou encore des épinards à un smoothie ou
plus et offrez les épinards le sait une
légumes à camoufler dans un smoothie
pour améliorer l' équilibre de notre
microbiote on pense moins à ce qu'il
faut enlever qu'est-ce qu'il faut
ajouter l'excès de certains aliments
peut nuire à l'équilibré du microbiote
la viande en excès l'alcool en excès les
produits transformés en excès qui
contiennent beaucoup d'additifs
alimentaires ça semblerait que ça peut
un peu nuire à l' équilibre de notre
microbiote stéphanie côté a publié un
livre sur le sujet il ya huit ans le mot
microbiote en 2016 et est très peu connu
on a pris mon livre la santé par
l'intestin ça veut dire que tous les
aspects de la santé passe par
l'interstate un déséquilibre du
microbiote peut entraîner de
l'inflammation et le développement de
certaines maladies selon andréanne il
faut toujours plus de variété ce que la
science nous dit actuellement c'est un
minimum de 30 aliments variés par
semaine pour aller chercher cette belle
diversité là dans notre microbiote
intestinal quand on mange toujours les
mêmes aliments bio ont fini par nourrir
toujours les mêmes bactéries écoutez le
microbiote il ya une foule de
département à gérer que ce soit
l'énergie la production des
neurotransmetteurs la synthèse des
hormones et j'en passe pour que tous
ceux que ce faire on a besoin d
expertise de chacune des espèces
bactériennes les bactéries de printemps
ils vont aussi former les cellules
immunitaires donc tout notre système
immunitaire et environ 80% de nos
cellules immunitaires qui se retrouvent
dans notre paroi intestinale
le défi se poursuit au dîner pourquoi
pas ajoutez au sandwich du midi un
aliments fermentés comme le kimchi les
aliments fermentés apportent avec eux
bon nombre de micro organismes donc à
eux seuls viennent bonifier notre
diversité microbienne justement kindschi
choucroute 1 le kéfir le tempo qui est
un seuil à fermenter le combo tchèque en
étant également
autre exemple au souper substituer le
riz blanc par du sarrasin ça ressemble à
du riz mais c'est comme en forme de
petits triangles la particularité en
fait du sarrasin c'est que c'est à la
fois un grès anti donc riche en fibres
mais à la fois riches en biotite la
nourriture de nos familles de bactéries
bénéfiques
alors on a envie encore là on se lance
pas juste dans le sarrasin en disant
c'est bon j'en mets partout la clé c'est
la variété
[Musique]
quand un panier d'épicerie coûte très
cher il ya toujours moyen de quand même
nourrir son microbiote et je pense que
l'aliment par excellence pour le faire
ce sont les légumineuses les pois
chiches les lentilles et les haricots
noirs les haricots rouges l'air co
toutes les couleurs on peut en faire des
soupes des sautes et des salades même le
mélanger à de la viande ça peut même
diminuer le coût de notre site d'à peu
près la moitié
des changements à faire selon nous
tolérance et à notre rythme mais vous
savez votre microbiote intestinal il
peut changer en dans 24 heures donc
c'est sûr que sur un mois on va les
avoir les impacts poste
[Musique]